leaving the jews robert rosen argues
that president franklin d
roosevelt did not abandon the european
jews during world war
ii he spoke about it at the 2006
roosevelt reading festival
for around 40 minutes
again my name is cynthia cook and i'm
the director of the franklin d roosevelt
presidential library and museum
and it is my pleasure this morning to
provide a brief
prologue to your session with robert n
rosen
author of saving the jews franklin d
roosevelt and the holocaust
this is a book whose essence
is summarized in the following words
was fdr friend or foe were simply
indifferent
to the jews in world war ii since the
1960s
when a post-world war ii generation of
historians came of age
the answer has seemed increasingly that
fdr was close to being ant
being an anti-semite after all the
holocaust took place on fdr's watch
why didn't the allies simply bomb the
camps
and then there is the recurring question
of the ss st
louis the boat packed with refugees that
was
infamously refused entry to the united
states and sent back to europe
the case is clear where is it
now in a rigorously researched narrative
and interpretive history
the record of the roosevelt in
administration is indisputably
laid bare and in robert rosen's
narrative it is a record to be proud of
the new dealers dealt with nazi
persecution courageously
and energetically it is a fearless
outstanding example
of historical detective work saving the
jews lays to rest once and for all the
canard
that roosevelt abandoned the jews of
europe and that america was a passive
callous bystander to the holocaust
robert rosen is a lawyer in charleston
south carolina
he holds an m.a in history from harvard
university
and has served on the board of directors
of the american jewish historical
society
and has served as president of the
jewish historical society of south
carolina
his previous books include a short
history of charleston
confederate charleston and illustrated
history of the city
and the people during the civil war and
the jewish confederates
his most recent work is saving the jews
franklin d roosevelt and the holocaust
welcome mr rosen thanks
so much i'll take my copy
well i'm very delighted to be here um
because
my grandfather arrived in america
and his sister was married to a tailor
and somebody came down from poughkeepsie
to get
a tailor on the lower east side of new
york and
i asked my grandfather i said why did
you go to poughkeepsie he said
dave goldberg his brother-in-law was a
tailor as a tailor
in poughkeepsie he said yeah there's
rich girls there they have a college
they needed a tailor so uh
so i'm also happy to have my family with
me here today my wife susan
and my son will and my daughter ally and
her friend daniel so
anyway we're delighted to be here in
fact this book was inspired
by a visit that ali and i had to the
holocaust memorial
in boston and if any of you have been to
boston you know there is a holocaust
memorial near
um quincy market and we went there and
on the memorial it said this i want you
to listen very carefully to this
statement
by late 1942 the united states
and its allies were aware of the death
camps
but did nothing to destroy them let me
read this to you again i want you to
listen to it very carefully
this is the origin of my book by late
1942
the united states and its allies were
aware of the death camps
but did nothing to destroy them now this
statement is
literally true and false at the same
time
i told ali that the statement cannot
possibly be true because the united
states was not even a belligerent in
world war ii
until december 7th 1941 when our fleet
was very badly damaged
and when we were certainly not geared up
for a war against
nazi germany so how could we have saved
the jews of europe in 1942
but as children will do she said dad i
don't think they put lies on holocaust
memorials
and i told her that although the
statement might be literally correct
i didn't think it was correct and i set
out to find out what it was all about
well it turns out that the statement
implies incorrectly in my view that we
americans were morally
culpable for failing to destroy death
camps
we were unable to destroy certainly in
1942
in in really in well into 1943 and 1944
and what i found when i got engaged in
this conversation was quite remarkable
in my opinion the biggest mistaken
interpretation of american history
ever unless it's the idea that the civil
war was fought over states rights that's
another mistaken interpretation
and it involved one of our most
important presidents franklin delano
roosevelt
a large group of historians rabbis
journalists
filmmakers activists people in the
jewish community
holocaust scholars the holocaust museum
have created a body of work which paints
fdr
his administration and the american
people as not
caring about the plight of european jury
and
even complicit in the holocaust
in the words of one of the most
prominent historian in this debate david
wyman the roosevelt and the american
people were
and listen to these words the
all-too-passive
accomplices of the nazis
accomplices now i'm a lawyer an
accomplice is a person who participates
in a crime many of you are familiar with
these books
uh the most well known are the
abandonment of the jews by wyman
while six million died by arthur d morse
among many others and with this version
of history because this version of
history has pretty much taken over
the general history when you pick up a
book on american history now this is the
view
uh of roosevelt and the american people
during the holocaust the only problem is
that in my opinion after six years of
research
they are wrong um these are the main
charges against
roosevelt his failure to save the
passengers on the saint louis in 1939
his failure to change
the immigration laws and to speak out
against the holocaust
and his refusal to bomb auschwitz and
let me deal with each one of these
um the st louis critics say
that roosevelt refused to let refugees
come to america and the st louis of
course is the most
dramatic example there was a movie in
the 1970s 80s the voyage of the dam
which by the way is more accurate than
many of the histories of the st
louis reversing the usual thing the
films are usually wrong and books are
right
but let the facts speak for themselves
the st louis sail from hamburg in may of
1939
before world war ii or the final
solution had even begun
it arrived in cuba the jewish passengers
had purchased
visas which were illegal under cuban law
and the cuban president would not honor
them uh the state department and the
american
jewish joint distribution committee
a lot of words which i will refer to as
the joint
uh work day and night to convince the
cubans to take in the passengers
the joint even sent a jewish lawyer down
there with a suitcase full of money
to bribe the cuban government the way
things were done in those days
henry morgenthau jr roosevelt's
jewish secretary of the treasury was the
person in charge of the coast guard
was personally involved in trying to
save the passengers sadly
all of their efforts failed but 29 of
the 936 passengers got off from cuba
even though the roosevelt administration
urged the cuban government to allow the
remaining 907 passengers to land
the st louis began to its return to
europe
with the active intervention of the
state department and the joint
the st louis went to england not to
germany
where 288 of the 907 passengers
disembark
and survive the holocaust most of my
jewish friends believe the
the st louis went directly to hamburg
and the passengers went to auschwitz
auschwitz hadn't been built yet the
remaining 619 disembarked
not in germany but in antwerp and went
to france belgium and holland countries
which were at peace uh with germany and
had large armies
the leading authorities on the st louis
estimate that 200
excuse me 392 of the 619 who disembarked
at antorup survived the war
thus what really is not in much dispute
now
uh two-thirds of the passengers of the
st louis survived the holocaust
the passengers knew that america
had saved them our gratitude is as
immense
as the ocean on which we are now
floating they wired
morris tropper of the joint now three
years later
this is june of 1939. three very long
and difficult years later world war ii
begins september
october uh 1939 three years later
the nazis reach into the netherlands and
belgium and take
jews out but of course no one knew that
in 1939 no could nor could anyone have
predicted it
death camps didn't even exist in 1939.
the roosevelt administration and
american jury had done everything they
possibly could to save the passengers on
the st
louis but why did we not let the
passengers
on the st louis end and people can't
seem to understand this
but you have to go back into american
history which everybody knows you all
took american history
america had taken an unlimited numbers
of immigrants in their late 19th and
early 20th century
we took in millions of very poor
poles slavs italians jews
and many many others in fact the
ancestors of most jews in america today
including
all of my grandparents emigrated between
1880 and 1920
but by the nineteen teens the great
majority of americans
feared these immigrants greatly
by the 1920s after the haymarket bombing
of 1886 by
anarchists in chicago the rise of
violent radical and even revolutionary
labor movements
the assassination of president william
mckinley in 1901 by who a polish
immigrant anarchist the bolshevik
revolution
of 1917 a minor event in history
the rise of the communist party uh in
the united states
and the dramatic increase in the number
of polish
and italian catholics uh slavs and jews
remember this was a white anglo-saxon
protestant country
great fear of the catholic church as
much as the bolsheviks
the jews and others a great fear of
those whose politics culture religion
dress language and behavior were very
foreign to the majority of americans
and americans demanded that the congress
curtail immigration and they did so in
very draconian laws
in 1921 and 1824 and if you wonder
about the intensity of the immigration
debate read today's paper
read next week's paper this is a
constant theme in american history
but in 1924 all immigration was cut off
except for a quote of 150
000 people the statue of liberty would
still stand in new york harbor
muldwin jones observed but the verses on
its base
would henceforth be but a tribute to a
vanished ideal
the immigration laws were amended by an
overwhelming vote in the senate
62-6 house of representatives 326-71
thus when hitler came to power and began
persecuting jews
america was no longer the land of asylum
that it had traditionally been
a strict quarter system was put in place
15 years
before the voyage of the st louis 17
years before the final solution began
every historian who's ever written about
this including roosevelt's most severe
critics acknowledged
it was a political impossibility to
change these laws
we must also keep in mind that when
roosevelt came to office in 1933
the great depression overshadowed
everything else
holocaust historians right without
reference to the great depression or
world war two
the country was in a a terrible
affliction
the banks were closed there were
radicals on the right radicals on the
left
tens of millions of americans were
unemployed in the long blighted
countryside david kennedy wrote
unmarketable crops rotted in fields and
unsaleable
livestock died on the hoof in towns and
cities across the country haggard men in
shaggy overcoats
collars turned up against the chill wind
newspapers plugging the holes in their
shoes lined up glumly
for handouts at soup kitchens there was
no possibility in the thirties
of the united states opening its doors
to any more immigrants
regardless of their religion race or
tragic situation
the passengers on the st louis were
among many many people in this world
europeans especially who were dying to
come to america
the anti-nazis the people who had
opposed hitler were being chased around
europe
the anti-fascists all over europe labor
leaders
the the rebels side of the spanish civil
war all
labor leaders of all stripes there were
many many people begging roosevelt
and the american congress to let them in
and they were all refused entry
let me mention crystal night because a
lot of people missed this point crystal
night is the
nazi program november 1938
between 33 and 38 many of the jews of
germany and austria left i'll get to
that in a minute
but crystal night really crystallized
for everyone the fact that jews could
not stay in germany
roosevelt was outraged by the nazis
treatment of german jews he thought
hitler was literally insane
after the crystal night program he
recalled our ambassador to germany
no other country did that roosevelt was
shocked by the accident
actions of the nazis i myself could
scarcely believe
that such things could occur in a 20th
century civilization
he said in a press conference quoted
around the world
no united states ambassador ever
returned to germany
until we defeated the nazis and
roosevelt was the only
important leader in the world to
criticize the germans about crystal
night
contrary to popular belief and in the
face of strict immigration quotas both
the leadership of the american jewish
community and the roosevelt
administration
were actively involved in trying to save
as many jews
as they reasonably could prior to the
outbreak of world war ii in september
1939 and the fall of france 1940
and i want you to listen to these
statistics 25
of all german jews had fled from germany
between 1933 and 1937.
in september 1939 the german jewish
population which had been 550 000
was down to 185 000 meaning 340
000 german jews 65 percent had fled
prior to world war ii
of the 185 000 jews in austria which
have been a next to germany 126
000 had emigrated by 1940.
between 1933 and 1942 161 000 jews came
to the united states
between 1938 and 1940 50
percent of all immigrants to the united
states were jews
between 1938 and 1940 50 percent of all
immigrants were jews the united states
accepted about
twice as many refugees as the rest of
the world combined
two hundred thousand of three hundred
thousand and what people are mixed up
about is
is that until the fall of france um
we were allowing people to come in but
when france fell this stunned
the world france's army had been larger
than the german army people could not
believe
the incredible ability of the german
army
to so swiftly conquer not only france
but norway denmark poland the
netherlands and belgium
in this atmosphere roosevelt was not
about to admit any
european immigrants in world war one
germans had sent saboteurs to the united
states blew up
uh munitions facilities in new york city
not
near new york city everybody in this
country was opposed
to any more immigrants coming in the
possibility of terrorists
bombing american military targets we
closed down our borders to protect
ourselves
and of course there was a tremendous
consensus that the
immigration laws could not be changed
meanwhile hitler's
chief victims were not the jews of
germany
uh the estimates are between 65 and 72
percent of german and austrian jews
survived the holocaust
of the nearly six million jews who were
murdered in the holocaust four million
five hundred sixty-five thousand
were polish and russian and 125 000 were
german
we have to keep in mind as roosevelt's
critics apparently
do not that the german army and the ss
controlled every aspect of life
in what hitler term fortress europe from
france
to germany to poland at one point to the
gates of moscow
norway denmark czechoslovakia
the jews of europe could only be saved
by the defeat
of the massive german war machine and we
must also remember which roosevelt's
critics always forget
that after pearl harbor our nation's
mission was the defeat
of not one but two
genocidal tyrannies the nazis
and the japanese militarists who had
attacked us
and killed over two thousand americans
at pearl harbor
during world war two and why people
don't know this i don't know
the japanese committed genocide on a
massive scale
they murdered 20 million
asian civilians the japanese murdered 20
million asian civilians you want to know
why the chinese and
don't like the japanese today the united
states was in a vicious war
with the japanese who by the way the
american people detested far more than
the germans
roosevelt however understood that the
germans
had to be defeated first now the final
solution
the extermination of the jews of europe
began with the german
invasion of the soviet union in june
1941.
roosevelt had been reelected he ran
against wilkie on a platform of keeping
us out of war
america americans
refused to be drawn into world war ii
roosevelt did everything he could
in my opinion to get us into world war
two but massive massacres
such as the murder of 33 000 at baby yar
occurred in september 1941 before the
united states was even in world war ii
so by the end of 1942 the year on this
holocaust memorial statement hitler was
the master of europe from norway
to north africa from the atlantic ocean
to the gates of moscow
he was able to annihilate six million
jews in poland
the soviet union and europe as he had
absolute control of the killing fields
those who say that the roosevelt
administration and the american people
were silent about the holocaust
are wrong again roosevelt denounced the
massacre of the jews in the strongest
possible terms
beginning in august 1942 which is about
when the world
realized that these terrible massacres
were going on of course they didn't
understand the holocaust
then the way we understand it now war
criminals he said would face
fearful retribution the state department
made the most vigorous representations
possible to the french vichy government
protesting the deportation of the jews
as early as october 7th
1942 roosevelt warned the nazi leaders
that the allies were aware of their war
crimes
and that it was the intention of this
government that the successful close of
the war
shall include provisions for the
surrender to the united nations meaning
the allies
of war criminals and that criminals
would receive
certain punishment this is the origin of
the nuremberg trials
rabbi stephen wise who is also much
maligned by roosevelt's critics unjustly
and other jewish leaders met with
roosevelt on december 8
1942 to request that the president issue
a declaration
condemning the massacre of the jews
specifically
the united nations declaration on jewish
massacres was issued on december 17
1942 nine days after rabbi wise and his
delegation requested it
signed by the united states great
britain the soviet union and eight
occupied countries it denounced
quote this is a quote on the front page
of the new york times in december of
1942
in the strongest possible terms this be
steel policy
of cold-blooded extermination it
condemned the german government's quote
intention to exterminate the jewish
people in europe the declaration
received wide
publicity in the american press it was
on the front page of the new york times
in the eyes of the world it committed
the allies to prosecute war crimes
against the jewish people
and would not have happened but for
roosevelt's strong
concern for the jews of europe why this
declaration
is barely quoted by legions of
roosevelt's critics
and hidden away by others i do not know
i will leave that to you
michael beschloss in his best seller the
conquerors
entitles his chapter on the subject the
terrible
silence and claims there was a
conspiracy of silence
but there was no conspiracy and
roosevelt was certainly not silent
the jews of europe have been helpless
prisoners since 1940
3.5 million jews were dead by december
1942.
3.5 million were dead by december 1942
one year after pearl harbor the
holocaust happens very quickly
not until the norman invasion normandy
invasion could we begin the process of
liberating
hitler's jewish prisoners held beyond
france
beyond germany in poland a far away
place
until may 1943 by the way
we were losing the battle of the
atlantic another thing these
roosevelt critics conveniently ignore is
world war ii
you know there was a war going on
we could not invade europe let alone
rescue jews in poland
roosevelt's critics do not seem to know
that until may
1943 more american ships were sunk by
german u-boats
then succeeded in arriving in great
britain
thousands of merchant mariners died in
the freezing waters of the north
atlantic
churchill later admitted that the u-boat
was the only thing that really
frightened me during the war
if hitler had put more time and effort
in the u-boats he may very well may have
won the war
the germans never came so near to
disrupting communication between the new
world and the old world
as in the first 20 days of march 1943
the admiralty staff concluded
from the allied point of view samuel
elliott morrison observed
victory was not even in sight this is
mid-1943
even in the face of this difficult
military situation henry morgenthau jr
and others
convinced roosevelt to establish the war
refugee board
in 1944 by executive order this is an
agency the american government
designed to rescue the jews of europe he
warned the hungarians the last surviving
jewish community in europe in march 1944
to not participate
in what he called quote one of the
blackest crimes of all history
begun by the nazis in the days of peace
and multiplied by them a hundred times
in times of war the wholesale systematic
murder of the jews of europe goes on
unabated every hour he promised again
swift punishment to the nazis
the united nations has made it clear he
said that they will pursue the guilty
and deliver them up in order that
justice be done
now the accomplishments of the war
refugee board are in dispute and are
very controversial
and very complex but whatever it did
accomplish
and some historians argue that it saved
up to 200 000 jews
was accomplished with funds from the
american jewish community once again the
joint
these are the assimilated reformed
german jews of new york who are also
vilified by these same critics these are
the people who raised the money
to save the jews of europe um the joint
and the roosevelt administration
for example the savior of many jews raul
wallenberg
who was lionized by these same critics
and who is the great hero
in the holocaust is called by these same
critics a quote swedish
diplomat but in fact
he was an agent of the war refugee board
the roosevelt administration and the
joint
all he did was carry out the plans of
the war refugee board
jewish agencies in america and the
roosevelt administration he would never
have gone to hungary
but for the war refugee board and the
joint i mean god bless the swedes but
they didn't put the money up that raul
wallenberg spent so freely
the donations of american jews and the
act
active participation of the roosevelt
administration is what caused wahlenberg
to succeed
and finally we have this issue of
auschwitz
a very explosive and very emotional
non-issue there is no question that
american bombers could have bombed
auschwitz some of
uh roosevelt's defenders take the
position that it was impossible but i
don't agree with them
not only could we have bombed auschwitz
we did bomb outfits i mean american
planes bombed the auschwitz area
between may 1944
and november 44 everybody agrees that's
the window of time and by the way what
was going on
the d-day invasion right but no one
wanted to bomb
auschwitz forget about the logistics
here's what actually happened
no one was in favor of the bombing of
auschwitz
especially jews the overwhelming
majority of the jewish leadership
worldwide including such notable
anti-semites as david ben-gurion
the first prime minister of israel
uh the executive agency uh
jewish agency for palestine the
beginning of the government of israel
the world jewish congress adamantly
opposed the bombing of auschwitz
we do not know the truth concerning the
entire situation in poland ben gurion
says
in these official minutes of the jewish
agency and it seems we will be unable to
propose anything concerning the matter
they voted against the bombing of
auschwitz eleven to one
one member of the jewish agency said it
is forbidden for us
to take responsibility for a bombing
that could very well cause the
death of even one jew a leon kubowitzke
himself a refugee from nazi occupied
europe
and a jew hardly an anti-semite head of
the rescue department of the world
jewish congress
wrote to the head of the war refugee
board john pele
and he underlined it i had the letter in
my hand the onion skin copy
at the american jewish archives in
cincinnati the destruction of the death
installations cannot be done by bombing
from the air as
the first victim would be the jews who
are gathered in these camps
and such bombing would be a welcome
pretext for the germans to assert
that their jewish victims have been
massacred not by their killers but by
the allied bombings
despite erroneous assertions blatantly
erroneous assertions by many historians
in the united states holocaust memorial
museum jewish leaders overwhelmingly
opposed the bombing of auschwitz
kubo witzki wrote to another jewish
leader i think you know
that we are not in favor of the bombing
of the extermination installations
because we believe in shah
hebrew literally life of the hour
meaning
those currently living and we are afraid
for the jewish victims of such bombings
and giving the germans an alibi the
holocaust museum
took one of kubowitzke's letters there's
a whole series of these letters
they blew it up into a very big letter
a very big exhibit at the holocaust
museum uh
and they made it appear that
kubowitzke who's on record is opposing
the bombing
was requesting the bombing of auschwitz
why they did this you would have to ask
them it's not true
the letter is the centerpiece of the
museum's
display on the bombing of auschwitz and
the letter
that they blew up is simply kubowitzke
passing on a request
from the czechoslovak government in
exile that the
camps be bombed there were some people
who thought they should
but the letter is addressed to john
mccloy
who's you know demonized in these
histories the assistant secretary of war
but of course mccloy was well aware that
kubowitzke and the world jewish congress
and the american jewish leadership
adamantly opposed the bombing of
auschwitz now i have
brought this blatant error to the
attention
of the holocaust museum and i got a nice
polite form letter back
saying we will pass it on to our chief
historian
i'll keep you posted
the representatives of all major jewish
organizations met with pele the director
of the war refugee board
on august 16 1944 and there's a record
of the meeting
none were in favor of the bombing of
auschwitz so this is a controversy
created by historians never existed at
the time
and plays to people's emotions today
now what can we finally say about
franklin roosevelt the holocaust
well i do want to say this
franklin roosevelt had the support of
ninety percent of american jews when he
ran for president
the jews have three veltan
dryvelton in yiddish velatin were
worlds the jews have three worlds
developed
this world yenavelt the next world
and roosevelt that's how the jews felt
about roosevelt
the jews alive at the time who knew him
i will leave you with the views of two
contemporary rabbis
on fdr's death men the world over will
ever be grateful to god
rabbi max kleinman said in his eulogy of
roosevelt
this is the man who stood
at the helm in a position to give
leadership to the american people in the
dark hours of ruthless
nazi barbarism seeking to destroy the
work of ages
and rabbi david matt said as to the jews
in europe
and the jewish aspirations in palestine
roosevelt was a powerful and sympathetic
friend
and spokesman his passion for justice
and his innate over-mastering desire
to aid the underprivileged those who are
most in need of help
explain his great interest in the
welfare of the jews of the world
who were the first and the greatest
sufferers from nazism and fascism
thank you all very much i've enjoyed
being with you
thank you very much thank you a very
compelling argument
very compelling i'm sure that mr rosen
would be happy to answer some questions
from members of the audience
and i will serve to moderate that
mr swift
certainly been a lot um negative
criticism about joe kennedy
i was very interested in your book that
he took a positive role in the
st louis situation helping out to get
some of his refugees into
england and i'm just curious any other
comments
yes i'll repeat i'll repeat the question
um you're working on a book on joseph p
kennedy who is the united states
ambassador to the court of saint james
in great britain in 1939
and that i had mentioned him in the st
louis incident and what is my view of
him well of course the jewish community
views
uh joe kennedy as one of the biggest
anti-semites you know in american
history
and they don't like joseph p kennedy in
fact when jack kennedy ran for president
he had to
mend a lot of fences uh but in this
instance in this instance
joe kennedy was scared to death that we
were going to get in a war and um and he
really didn't want his boys
in in that war and he wanted to avoid
the war so he was trying to
defuse the situation so he used all of
his efforts
to to defuse the situation in other
words he worked
to get the passengers into great britain
and he succeeded so in that
in the case of the st louis i know the
jewish community doesn't want to hear
this but he actually did the right
thing maybe did it for the wrong reasons
first meetings in london with rabbi
stephen wise who wrote fdr
there's a letter here saying what a
wonderful guy was and how much he was
going to help so
right well he he was kennedy was very
interested in trying to get hitler to
calm down
and uh he but you know he didn't work
but but
i think i think his heart was in the
right place in the overall scheme of
things
yes yes ma'am community
morally or religiously didn't want
auschwitz bomb
but the same people were begging that
they should bomb the
train tracks leading and bringing
inmates into auschwitz and nothing
happened
not really um her question is people um
the argument about bombing the camps is
not the same as applied to the railroad
tracks
let me explain this i'll try and say
this as simply as i can
in world war ii in order to bomb a
railroad track um
you would have to take an airplane with
men on it and fly them over the railroad
track and photograph it
all right now and the plane could be
shot down in that mission so you have to
make a judgment
about whether you want to risk the lives
of people my my
my stepfathers not stepfathers
mother-in-law's husband's brother
was a photographer well it's important
because i talked to him about his
brother was killed
uh flying one of these missions
photographing things so people die
doing these things then when you
photograph it you then have to bomb it
and when you bomb it you then risk other
planes and and you know we didn't have
pinpoint bombing
there's a myth about world war ii you
know
you you have a big plane in the air you
might hit the railroad tracks you might
not
but here's the thing about railroad
tracks two hours later
the german army would repair the railway
track okay so the military people
know and military historians know that
bombing railroad tracks
is a waste of time first of all there's
seven or eight railroad tracks leading
from hungary
to auschwitz so you bomb one they take
them on another number one number two
they'll be repaired in a matter of hours
and days listen i'm from south carolina
even the confederate army could repair
railroad tracks
okay so you know yes sir i can
understand the situation about the
i can understand the situation about the
railroads but there's certainly no
reason why they couldn't bond the rail
heads
the rail heads yeah i think if you look
at world war ii
and you want to redesign the war in
other words if you want to take the
planes away
from bombing real military targets
in france so that fewer american troops
will die
you certainly could do that in other
words eisenhower almost resigned
because i don't know you i found this
the most astounding thing in my whole
research
eisenhower did not control the air force
did you know the army air corps the army
air force
was independent of eisenhower's command
he threatened to resign if they didn't
give him the air force for six to eight
weeks
to soften up france for the norm in the
invasion i don't disagree with you
we could have taken our entire air force
pulled it away from normandy and bombed
railroad tracks and railroad heads
leading to auschwitz does that make any
sense
it doesn't make any sense to me but what
we were trying to do is win the war
and we could have diverted all of our
troops ships and planes to saving
auschwitz
but roosevelt was defending the whole
world
and he had to make brutal choices and
and we simply didn't have
unlimited you know air power to do that
yeah
it was really the army air corps
decision of the tactical decisions of
what the bomb
well exactly and they're not gonna and
we're not gonna decide based on what the
jewish leadership in uh
in palestine is saying in terms of where
they're gonna bomb right it's gonna be
it's a military it's a military decision
look you know air warfare is a huge
subject which i'm not qualified
to be an expert on but i did try to read
as much as i could to educate myself
about it
the the air barons you know space spats
and uh the the british air baron thought
they could win the war just with air
power we could bomb germany into
submission
that failed we had to have troops on the
ground to win the war
so they used the air force to to bomb
the railways
and other facilities leading to normandy
so that we we would be able to win the
war
um and i think you know hindsight's
2020. if i if i could go back right now
i would redo the battle of gettysburg
you know
my son will and i you know uh crossed
the field
uh gettysburg to the confederate army
cross and you can see it's pretty
obvious it's a very long way to get to
that wall
and that's why they lost so you know if
somebody wants me to go back and tell
robert e lee how to win the battle i can
do it
i could definitely do it yeah
was in the eighth air force and he flew
from 25 missions over
germany during that same time period and
there's the websites about the 432nd air
and approximately like 70 percent of all
the uh
uh crews were killed were killed that's
right at that time at that same time
period
and those planes were lost right
and they list the missions like my uncle
did it was like all submarine bases oil
fields it was not
exactly that exactly yes sir
i just want to compliment you
i don't have any questions but your book
was long
overdue thank you i mean uh thank you
i'm in the process of reading it i'm in
the middle of the book
i should have brought it up with me for
you to autograph but then they might
have thought i was
lifting it from you mail it to me you
mail it to me in charleston south
carolina i'll mail it right back
all right one more thing i
you have rehabilitated
fdr with regard to the holocaust
much in the same way gordon prang
rehabilitated him with regards to pearl
harbor
yuri you are mentioned
miracle at midway in your book and
you know up until uh at dawn we slept in
1980
roosevelt had been accused by his
critics of
being responsible for pearl harbor
no quote knowing about it beforehand
well you know the story
and gordon prang just turned him upside
down
thank you very much uh thank you
congratulations i'm halfway through your
book at this time
it's if i got you halfway through it
must be good yeah
i i'm i'm gonna buy a stack of these
books
we have a close friend in california in
the film industry
who said that eddie cantor was
advocating for the saint louis
passengers
absolutely eddie cantor is a great
american jew in fact a lot of people
don't know there's a lot to him
oh yeah he wrote roosevelt actually ken
moody my research
ace is here uh and he sent me a lot of
cantor's letters to after he was always
writing fdr
okay yes sir
you please tell us the two major
criticisms you've received from other
authors or
critics well i expect um i expect to
receive some criticism
um uh i have been accused already of
of writing a lawyer's brief uh for
roosevelt and
i'm an apologist for roosevelt and
anyone who reads the book can see that i
i think that i've mentioned several
things about him that were you know not
i mean i'm not you know everything he
did wasn't right
i expect that the wyman institute and a
lot of those people will have a lot to
say
and i will have a lot to say back
thank you all very much
mr rosen will be signing books at his
table and he'll be here
throughout the day so if you don't get
your book purchased and signed
in the next 15 or 20 minutes and you
want to go to another session and please
feel free to do so because
he'll be with us and he'll be doing
throughout the afternoon as well thank
you i think that was very illuminating
and i know there's a lot more to talk
about with this and we look forward to
hearing from you again thank you mr
rosen from the 2006 roosevelt reading
festival
robert rosen on his book saving the jews
for more information on president
franklin d roosevelt
visit fdrlibrary.marist.edu
non-fiction authors all weekend you're
watching book tv on c-span 2.
coming up at 1 pm eastern public schools
public menace
joel turtle says that public schools are
failing america's children
then a writer's life gay talis reflects
on over 50 years in journalism and
non-fiction writing
tonight on book tv encore book notes
from 1997
james humes on his career as a
speechwriter for five republican
presidents
after